things you talk about in the book as you  say an indulgent and prosperous nation  readily forgave Bill Clinton give me  your assessment of the nation and its  moral judgment yet made on the president  you talk about prosperity yeah I think  the first of all the system did work our  system of checks and balances work that  is the president was held accountable he  in fact had to answer to articles of  impeachment but at the same time the  American people are very forgiving and  we also want stability and so one of the  messages of this book is be careful  about impeachment impeachment is hell  and putting the nation's through that  process is really quite wrenching  because